a man who fought off a mountain lion
like that one why I oughta
is giving harrowing details of his
desperate fight for survival for the
first time 31 year-old Travis Kaufman
spotted the animal while running along
trails in the Colorado mountains near
Fort Collins earlier this month Mireya
Villarreal shows us how he managed the
extraordinary escape a warning some of
these images are disturbing it started
to claw at my face and neck and that's
when kind of my fear response turned
into more of a fight response
Travis Coffman recalled the moment a
routine run turned into a fight for his
life with a young mountain lion it
really clicked after I hit it and head
of the rock and it still didn't release
my wrist that at that point more drastic
measures were necessary
he took wildlife Rangers back to the
scene to show how he positioned himself
on top of the animal putting his foot on
its neck until it let go while wondering
if another attack was imminent I was
just very concerned that mom was gonna
come out of nowhere and at that point
that fight would be over pretty quickly
after suffocating the lion Kaufman
bloodied and battered made his way back
down the trail where he ran into some
other joggers who helped him get to the
hospital there he got more than two
dozen stitches on his face and hands if
you run sometimes it appears that'll
trigger them to chase after Jason clay
with the Colorado Department of Parks
and Wildlife says mountain lion attacks
on humans are very rare mountain lions
are very elusive and you don't
necessarily walk up the trail and always
see one like you may see a deer but they
are around us Coffman says the
frightening experience has not changed
his love for the outdoors
I will go round those trails again I
will go with the buddy down for CBS this
morning midday AVL Fort Collins Colorado
there's lucky to be alive is his
girlfriend was with him at the press
conference and she said friends called
her and said you better lock that guy up
you will always feel safe when you're
with him
later on yeah